[Music]
once there was a place in the woods
where they sent people who didn't fit
into the real world welcome jacob
species identity disorder can be cured
so that a person who thinks themselves
an animal
can resume a happy healthy
and rewarding life i want to do it it's
the best thing for everyone
[Music]
you're all gonna end up wonderful human
beings
they say the wolf and the wildcat are
natural enemies
but they're wrong
how long have you been here
since i can remember
i'm putting you out of your misery
you're calling the zookeeper
keep clear of him just don't ever think
of running away
only one person ever did
i've always had this feeling
these instincts
stop
you're gonna get us
i
once upon a time
there was a wolf
and a wild cat
i wanted to live happily ever after
it's not just about surviving but
surviving is me
do you really think you can have a life
with that boy
[Music]
but life is no fairy tale
[Music]
i'm breathing
i'm
do you want things to get worse for you
i have no human form
i have no human form
jacob
what have they done to you
[Music]
you